gambling it's the foundation of our
economy it can also be addictive march
is problem gambling awareness month and
this morning we're highlighting what one
local center is doing to try and help
mary jane bellies is live on the las
vegas strip with more details on that
mary jean good morning
good morning to you john i spoke with
those at the problem gambling center who
tell me their mission is all about
evaluation and helping those with
gambling problems and addictions they
say right now their biggest hurdle is
getting people in to get help ted
hartwell is a consultant at the center
he knows all too well of the impact
addiction can play in your life now
while hartwell recognized a gambling
habit started to form it actually took
him two years before he realized he
needed professional help
really
i'm kind of obsessed with this idea of
the potential to hit this big jackpot
and solve a lot of problems in my life
which were all quite frankly only being
made worse
because of my gambling i saw myself get
into financial trouble i saw myself
start to
lie to my family and to co-workers about
what i was doing
now hartwell remains gamble free for
more than 13 years and says raising
awareness is his way of giving back now
if you'd like to learn more about the
problem gambling center or if you're
struggling with addiction you can call
that number on your screen that's
702-363-0290
reporting live from the strip mary jane
vallezza live local now